3.4 million people who are dealing with
the aftermath of the hurricanes which
hit puerto rico and the virgin islands
nearly two weeks ago
uh look we have a tragedy we're gonna
do
and what happened in las vegas
is in many ways a miracle the police
department has done such an incredible
job
and we'll be talking about gun laws as
time goes on
but i do have to say
how quickly the police department was
able to get in
[Music]
well i think she's come back a long way
and uh
you know i think it's now acknowledged
what a great job we've done and people
are looking at that and
in texas and in florida we get an a-plus
and i'll tell you what i think we've
done just as good in puerto rico and
it's actually a much tougher situation
but now the roads are cleared
communication's starting to come back we
need their truck drivers their drivers
have to start driving trucks we have to
do that so at a local level they have to
give us more help but i will tell you
the first responders the military fema
they have done an incredible job in
puerto rico and
whether it's her or anybody else they're
all starting to say it i appreciate very
much the governor and his comments he
has said we have done an incredible job
and that's the truth
we'll talk about that later
he's a sick man a demented man
a lot of problems i guess and we're
looking into him very very seriously but
we're dealing with a very very sick
individual thank you thank you
on wednesday the senate budget committee
will consider senate republicans 2018
budget blueprint